ARROYO TO TELL US ALL.
BUT FIRST, THE RECKONING, THAT
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT SINGLE.
>> ALL RIGHT, TONIGHT ALONG WITH
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS, WE DO
CELEBRATE THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND THE
VINDICATION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, WE TOLD YOU FROM DAY ONE
THIS WAS AN INVESTIGATION
TRIGGERED BY PEOPLE WHO WANTED
TO UNDO THE RESULTS OF 2016
ELECTION.
WE TOLD YOU WEEK AFTER WEEK
AFTER WEEK THAT THIS PROBE
SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN LAUNCHED.
AND MUELLER'S FINDINGS HAVE NO
COLLUSION OR COORDINATION WITH
RUSSIA SHOWS THAT WE WERE RIGHT
AND THE BITTER, NASTY ANTI-TRUNK
FORCES WERE WRONG.
AND HOW LONG WERE THEY?
THEY WERE CONSPIRING WITH
RUSSIAN, AND >> IT IS SAYING
THAT NOBODY IN THE CAMPAIGN HAD
ANY CONTACTS WITH RUSSIA.
FALSE REPORTING IS SAYING THERE
IS NO SUGGESTION OF ANY KIND OF
COLLUSION.
>> HOW MANY MORE TIMES DOES HE
HAVE TO SAY COLLUSION AND THAT'S
BECAUSE HE FEELS COLLUDED.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
PLAY THESE SOUND BITES AND LAUGH
BECAUSE AFTER THESE TWO CODE
TURBULENT YEARS, AMERICA
DESERVES MORE THAN A DAY OR TWO
WITH MEDIA ANALYSIS AND ONE FAIR
HEADLINE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TODAY.
AMERICA DESERVES TO KNOW WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED HERE.
THE FORCES, THE INDIVIDUALS AND
THE MOTIVATION BEHIND THIS TOTAL
TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FACE REAL,
POLITICAL, LEGAL AND
PROFESSIONAL REPERCUSSIONS.
>> WE CAN NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN
TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT AGAIN.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT AND I SAY IT
STRONGLY, VERY FEW PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW COULD HAVE HANDLED IT.
WE CAN NEVER, EVER LET THIS
HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
>> Laura: THESE PAST 675 DAYS
WERE FILLED WITH UNFAIR
SLANDEROUS, DEFAMATORY, VICIOUS,
IRRESPONSIBLE AND ERRONEOUS
REPORTING AND COMMENTARY ABOUT
THIS PRESIDENT.
AND ALSO ABOUT HIS CURRENT AND
FORMER STAFF AND YES, HIS FAMIL
FAMILY.
>> THERE WAS ACTIVITIES WITH
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
SOME OF THAT WAS JARED KUSHNER'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
SOME OF IT WAS DONALD JR.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE INDICTMENTS
OF BOTH OF THOSE PEOPLE.
>> WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP JR. AND
ERIC JR. BRAGGED HOW MUCH MONEY
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION HAS
GOTTEN OUT OF RUSSIA.
>> ANY SIGNS OF COLLUSION WAS
GOING ON, SPENT HIS WHOLE LIFE
SEEKING HIS DAD'S APPROVAL.
FAILING AT IT AND NOW, TO BRING
DOWN TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
>> Laura: OH, SAMANTHA, THE
BEST.
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW, NAMING
NAMES OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION HALL OF SHAME.
WE WILL NOT FORGET, AND NEITHER
SHOULD YOU, THOSE WHO ACTED AND
SPOKE WITH SUCH A RECKLESS
DISREGARD OF THE TRUTH AND BASIC
STANDARDS OF PROFESSIONALISM.
THERE MUST BE A RECKONING.
IT IS TIME TO HOLD GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, REPORTERS, PENDANTS,
MEDIA EXECUTIVES AND YES,
POLITICIANS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ROLE IN THIS RUSSIAN
HOAX.
NOW WE START WITH THE RUSSIAN
HOAX POLITICAL HOLE OF SHAME.
AND WHY NOT BEGIN WITH
SENATOR TRICKY BLUMENTHAL FROM
THE HOME STATE OF CONNECTICUT?
AND WHEN HE COULD TALK ONLY OF
THE POSSIBLE MOSCOW TRUMP TOWER
DEAL IN RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
>> THE PROJECT NEVER HAPPENED IF
NOT FOR LACK OF TRYING AND NOT
FOR LACK OF DESIRE.
THE RUSSIANS KNEW THAT HE WAS
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ENABLED HIM, AND NOW, THEY
HAVE THAT LEVERAGE OVER HIM HERE
IT SO WE COMPROMISED.
>> Laura: WHO COMPROMISED NOW.
BLUMENTHAL MUST REALIZE THERE
WAS NO RUSSIAN LEVERAGE OVER THE
PRESIDENT, RIGHT, SURELY CHANGED
THE TUNE.
>> THE FACTS AND EVIDENCE HERE
ARE LIKELY TO SHOW A LOT OF
CRIMINALITY, A LOT OF WRONGDOING
AND A LOT OF LAWBREAKING THAT IS
NOT INDICTED HERE.
>> Laura: OKAY, HE WAS A STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
FOR THE SECOND ENTRY, LET'S MOVE
ON TO MATT MAXINE, SHALL WE?
BACK IN 2016.
>> THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES
COME I BELIEVE AND OTHERS
BELIEVE COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY AND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO STOP TALKING ABOUT IT.
ALL I KNOW IS THIS, IF HE THINKS
HE CAN STOP ME FROM TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHING, HE'S GOT
ANOTHER THOUGHT COMING.
I'M NOT INTIMIDATED BY HIM.
I'M GOING TO KEEP SAYING WE NEED
TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> Laura: BUT WHAT IS SHE
SAYING NOW?
HERE IS MAXINE YESTERDAY.
>> HE HAS BEEN SAYING NO
COLLUSION, NO COLLUSION, NO
COLLUSION OVER AND OVER AGAIN
FOR A LONG TIME NOW.
AND HE WILL TRY TO CONCLUDE THAT
THIS REPORT IS PROVING THAT
THERE IS NO COLLUSION, AND YOU
HAVE A LOT WHO WILL TAKE THE NOD
FROM HIM AND THEY WILL SAY THE
SAME THING.
BUT WE CANNOT ALLOW THEM TO GET
AWAY WITH THIS.
>> Laura: OKAY, SO LET ME GET
THIS STRAIGHT, MAXINE.
SO NOW, ANDREW WEISSMANN AND BOB
MUELLER ARE ALL PART OF A
PRO-TRUMP CONSPIRACY WITH WHITE,
LIGHT CONSERVATIVE JOURNALIST?
THE THIRD ENTRY IN THE POLITICAL
HALL OF SHAME GOES TO BEN AND
JERRY NADLER, I MEAN JERRY
NADLER, HOW DID THAT GET IN
THERE, AS STATESMEN LIKE JERRY,
SURELY HAS A DIFFERENT VIEW?
HERE HE WAS A FEW MONTHS AGO.
>> IT HAS BECOME VERY CLEAR AT
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS AND TRIED TO
SUBVERT THE ELECTION.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT TO BE
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT
APPEARS THAT TIME IS RUNNING OUT
WHEN HE CAN HOLD HIMSELF ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> Laura: WE KNOW NOW THAT
NEITHER THE PRESIDENT OR ANYONE
IN HIS ORBIT INDICTED FOR THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
I BET NADLER SEES THINGS
DIFFERENTLY NOW, RIGHT?
>> WE KNOW THERE WAS CONCLUSION.
>> BUT NONE OF WHAT YOU SAID IS
THE LEVEL OF CRIMINAL INDICTMENT
BY SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> NO, IT HASN'T AS FAR AS WE
KNOW.
BUT WE KNOW THERE WAS COLLUSION.
WHY THERE HAS BEEN NO
INDICTMENT, WE DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT HAS
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, YOU STILL
BELIEVE THAT?
THERE HAS BEEN OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE WITH HER CLEARLY
CRIMINAL OBSTRUCTION IS ANOTHER
QUESTION.
>> Laura: IT JUST TAKES YOUR
BREATH AWAY.
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION FOUND.
TWO YEARS OF INVESTIGATION, SIR.
BUT OF COURSE, HE SAYS THERE IS
OBSTRUCTION, WHAT?
THERE IS NO CRIMINAL COLLUSION
FOUND.
BUT HE SAYS WE KNOW THERE IS
COLLUSION, WHAT?
FOURTH ON THE LIST, CRAZY
MAISIE, HERE SHE IS LAST YEAR
PRESIDENT PARDON.
>> FOR HIM TO COME AND SAY HE
COULD PARDON HIMSELF AND SOME OF
THE OTHER OUTRAGEOUS STATEMENTS
HE THINK HE IS A DICTATOR AND A
KING.
IT SHOWS HE IS REALLY AFRAID OF
WHAT THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
WILL SHOW.
>> Laura: SO AFTER EVERYTHING
WE LEARNED OVER THE WEEKEND, SHE
IS DOING MY A COPE AND, RIGHT?
>> JUST BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT
ENOUGH EVIDENCE FOR A CRIMINAL
CHARGE OF CONSPIRACY DOES NOT
MEAN THAT A COZY RELATIONSHIP
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Laura: COZY STANDARD.
AND I ALWAYS SAY, BEING A
LIBERAL MEANS NEVER HAVING TO
SAY YOU ARE SORRY.
SHE IS JUST ACTING LIKE COME I
DON'T KNOW, ERIC SWALWELL WHO
FRANKLY MAKES ME UNWELL.
A PORTRAIT OF THE PRESIDENT
RIPPED FROM THE MARIO NOVEL.
>> IT IS SO OBVIOUS EAGER TO
COLLUDE WITH RUSSIA AT THAT NOW
WE SEE THERE WAS A CONSPIRACY TO
COVER UP.
IT'S LOOKING MORE AND MORE THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS A PART OF A
CRIMINAL CAMPAIGN BECOME A
CRIMINAL TRANSITION AND NOW
PRESIDES OVER A CRIMINAL PRESIDE
PRESIDES OVER A CRIMINAL PRESIDC
PRESIDES OVER A CRIMINAL PRESID.
>> WAIT A SECOND, AFTER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SPECIAL
COUNSEL CLEAR OF THE PRESIDENT
OF WRONGDOING, HE CHANGED HIS
MIND, RIGHT?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW WHETHER THIS
PRESIDENT VIOLATED CONDUCT AND
WHETHER HE VIOLATED NOT ONLY THE
LAW BUT THE HONOR CODE WE ALL
COUNT ON.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, HONOR
CODE?
IS THE PRESIDENT AND MEMBER OF
CODE SCOUT TROOP?
DID HE BREAK THE LAW OR NOT?
MUELLER AFTER TWO YEARS SAID HE
DID NOT BUT SWELL WELL,
SHAMELESS ADAM SCHIFF CAN'T LET
GO OF THEIR OWN NARRATIVES.
>> I CERTAINLY SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
>> THERE IS A REAL PROSPECT ON
THE DAY DONALD TRUMP LEAVES
OFFICE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
MAY INDICT HIM AND HE MAY BE THE
FIRST PRESIDENT IN QUITE SOME
TIME TO FACE THE REAL PROSPECT
OF JAIL TIME.
>> Laura: NO, WRONG NO GROUNDS
TO INDICT HIM AS MUELLER SAID
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT, TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND THE RUSSIANS.
SO YOU DID READ THE BAR LATER,
DIDN'T YOU, ADAM?
>> THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
REASONING WITH THIS PRESIDENT'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Laura: REPUBLICANS SHOULD
NOTE HERE THAT THE TENACITY OF
THESE PEOPLE, EVEN WHEN PROVEN
COMPLETELY WRONG, THEY PRESSED
THEIR CASE AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
IMAGINE WHAT REPUBLICANS COULD
DO WITH THAT KIND OF COMMITMENT?
ALL THESE DEMOCRATS SHOWED
HIDEOUSLY FLAWED JUDGMENT IN
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THEM
SHOULD FACE PRIMARY CHALLENGES.
ABSOLUTELY.
KELLYANNE CONWAY TOOK IT FURTHER
TODAY.
>> ADAM SCHIFF, HE BELIEVES THAT
THE SCANDAL IS SIZE AND SCOPE OF
WATERGATE AND PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
HE OUGHT TO RESIGN TODAY.
HE'S BEEN ON EVERY TV SHOW 50
TIMES A DAY TIMES A DAY FOR
PRACTICALLY THE LAST TWO YEARS
PROMISING AMERICANS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT WOULD EITHER BE
IMPEACHED OR INDICTED.
>> Laura: THESE DEMOCRATS AND
MANY MORE MADE A CATACLYSMIC
MISTAKE.
COUNTLESS HOURS ON TV, GIVING
SPEECHES, PRONOUNCING THE END OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY AND
LITERALLY ACCUSING OF SEDITIOUS
BEHAVIOR.
NOW, I DON'T THINK A LOT OF THEM
EVEN BELIEVE WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING BUT THEY DIDN'T CARE.
HATING TRUMP BECAME ITS OWN
COMPETITIVE SPORT NONETHELESS.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, TRUMP KEPT
PUSHING FORWARD, GROWING THE
ECONOMY, POINTING GREAT JUDGES,
TRYING TO UNTANGLE RED TAPE,
KILL REGULATIONS THAT SUFFOCATED
EXPANSION AND INNOVATION OF
BUSINESS, BUT THE DEMOCRATS,
WELL, THEY LEFT THEIR OWN PARTY
UNATTENDED.
THEY DID WELL IN THE MIDTERMS
BUT FACE IT, THEY WON BACK THE
HOUSE.
A LOT OF THAT WAS ANTI-TRUMP
STUFF FED BY THE RUSH OF
FALSEHOOD.
SUBSTANTIAL, WORKABLE IDEAS FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN.
WELL, WHAT DID THIS DO?
CREATED VACUUM OF IDEAS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH LEFT THE
DOOR OPEN TO SOCIALISM.
WHICH THE RADICALS WALKED RIGHT
THROUGH.
SO WHAT DID TWO YEARS OF BASHING
TRUMP REALLY GET THEM?
EVEN AFTER THE MUELLER REPORT,
THEY ARE THREATENING MORE
HEARINGS.
BUT OTHERWISE, DEMOCRATS ON THE
DEFENSE WITH INFIGHTING IN THE
RING WITH CHARGES OF
ANTI-SEMITISM AS THEY ARE NEW,
YOUNG RADICAL EMBRACED
COLLECTIVISM.
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE SHOULD
TAKE THIS MOMENT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESET AND
RELAUNCH HIS PRESIDENCY, FREE OF
THE ALBATROSS OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
IT IS NOW TIME TO TAKE IT ALL
INTO HIGH GEAR.
STRIKE A GOOD DEAL WITH CHINA IF
ONE CAN BE HAD, GET THIS BOARD
ARE SEALED, BILLED AS MUCH OF
THE WALL THAT HE CAN COMMIT TASK
ICE TO REMOVAL ORDERS AND DEPORT
THEM.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF A GREAT
TURN EFFECT AT THE BORDER.
SHOW THE COMPANY OF THE LEFT WAS
NOT JUST WRONG ON RUSSIA, THEY
WERE WRONG ON JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
GO TO THE INNER CITIES, GO TO
THE BLUE STATES, EXPAND THIS
MOVEMENT, SHOW YOUR HEART, YOU
ARE CHARMING.
AND HAVE FUN.
WINNING IS FUN.
NOW GLOATING WON'T GET YOU
REELECTED AND NEITHER WILL THE